stell dir mal vor du kochst für jemanden
und sagst du hast selbst gemachten ycki
gemacht die Person wird garantiert
beeindruckt sein und das beste ist es
geht total einfach wir kochen zunächst
einmal ein paar Kartoffeln die
Kartoffeln sind gekocht und abgegossen
und schön weich die gebe ich jetzt
einfach in Kartoffelpresse rein wir
pressen unsere Kartoffeln auf eine
milelierte Oberfläche und jetzt geben
wir ein Ei drauf und dann können wir
anfangen zu kneten und zwar so lange bis
unser Teig nicht mehr so klebrig ist wir
schneiden uns ein Stückchen ab und
Rollen daraus jetzt eine gnoci Schlange
und jetzt teilen wir unsere Schlange
einfach in gnoki Breite Stückchen auf
das könnte man jetzt so schon verwenden
wir wollen den aber noch diesen ycki
Look geben dafür nehmen wir einfach eine
Gabel und drehen die einfach einmal über
die Gabel drüber dann können wir unseren
ycki auch schon in kochendes Wasser
geben und die kurz kochen bis sie oben
schwimmen wir nehmen uns ein wenig
Salbei den zupfen wir in unsere Pfanne
in der wir Butter schmelzen
aromatisieren die geschmolzene Butter
ein wenig dann können wir auch unseren
ycki nehmen und in die Pfanne geben und
fertig sind die selbstgemachten ycki ab
in den Schüssel frischer schwarzer
Pfeffer und bergeweise Parmesan